राष्ट्रपति महोदय, आपकी अनुमति हो तो
रक्षा अलंकरण समारोह आरंभ किया।
अति असाधारण कोटि की विशेष सेवा के लिए
परम विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल लेफ्टिनेंट जनरल
दलबीर सिंह उत्तम युद्ध सेवा मेडल अति
विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल
लेफ्टिनेंट जनरल संजीव चाचरा अति विशेष
सेवा मेडल विशेष सेवा
मेडल वाइस एडमिरल सुरेंद्र पाल सिंह चीमा
अति विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल नौसेना मेडल
एयर मार्शल धनंजय परशुराम जोशी अति
विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल
एयर मार्शल रविकांत शर्मा अति विशिष्ट
सेवा मेडल वायुसेना मेडल
लेफ्टिनेंट जनरल जयप्रकाश नेहरा अति
विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल बार
लेफ्टिनेंट जनरल शक्ति गुरुंग उत्तम युद्ध
सेवा मेडल अति विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल विशिष्ट
सेवा मेडल
लेफ्टिनेंट जनरल सुरेंद्र हरी कुलकर्णी
अति विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल
बार
लेफ्टिनेंट जनरल सुब्रोतो मित्र अति
विशिष्ट सेवा मेडल सेना मेडल विशेष सेवा
मेडल